it's rare when i'm the second best
shooter on the show
it only happens occasionally uh
it certainly happens right now because
reggie miller is on the program reggie
called the heat and the bucks game the
lakers rockets
and tonight celtics raptors at nine
eastern good morning reg
how are you i'm great theodore good
morning and i would put
us as equal no that's not true
hey you're up there with me that hey
no do you realize i don't know if i ever
told you this story when we had ray
allen in studio
and no okay so i'm watching ray
shoot in the man cave and i said uh hey
the ball is resting on the palm of your
hand right
so i'm critiquing
so one of the top 10 shooters in the
history of mankind
i'm going to put him in top five ray's
top five okay
yeah the look he had on his face yes i
believe the
exact quote when you first talked to him
was you know you're doing that wrong
i don't know what made me sad but you
know you you shoot with your fingertips
he had it on his palm and he goes like
what are you talking about i said
i should be able to put my finger
underneath between the ball and your
hand
am i right with that wrench you're
you're right
with that but listen it goes to show you
that shooting are like fingerprints
they're everyone is totally different
and everyone has different release
points
my elbow is out when i shot ray has
textbook form with his elbow being in
so everyone is different but the fact
that you would
correct the all-time leader and
three-pointers made
in the nba
it's why you're theodore though i don't
lack confidence when it comes to
shooting
but and you're right you know you have
your elbow out and i remember when i was
shooting
and we had a basketball hoop at the
super bowl in
indianapolis and larry bird was watching
and larry came on
he said your elbow it's out and he was
critiquing my shot
because my elbow was out just like yours
so all right yeah just letting you know
hey
does the ball go in yeah exactly
that's all that matters do you realize
i'm still trying to perfect my shot
at my age with nothing to play for
are you do you do that i do when i do
it's like golf you know you know
even professional golfers still take
lessons and they still critique
themselves
and um i i think shooting and playing
the game of basketball is a lot like
golf
because there is no such such thing as
perfection
and it's interesting because when i was
calling
the lakers games last night because
their offense right now
it's it's like been on hiatus it hasn't
it has not found its way to the bubble
yet yeah and they were playing so great
up to that point and they're shooting if
you look at their numbers
i believe we mentioned it over their
last two games
they're like six four fifty
from three and you're wondering is it
legs
do they have are they tired uh are they
it it
their offense just not seen does not
seem to be in sync
and this is with little i know lebron
didn't play last night
but two nights ago versus okc he played
but what
how concerned would you be if you're a
laker fan right now
i i said this on air last night i
understand they have the number one seat
in the west
and they are trying different things
trying to figure out but you've got to
have some type of rhythm
going into the playoffs and
everyone is in a unique situation here
where
i wouldn't be as concerned if they were
playing in staples
in front of 20 000 fans and you get that
energy
and you get a little pumped up you are
in a unique
environment where home court will not
matter
and if you don't have a great rhythm
starting the playoffs on august 17th
to me that's the only thing that's
that's a little unsettling is because
they don't have a rhythm yet offensively
the only team in the bubble the lakers
with lebron james
and anthony davis that are not averaging
100 points with those two great players
it's a little concerning for me
everybody is scoring in the bubble
except for the lakers but is there a
reason why everybody is
let's take the lakers out of the
equation why is it that scoring is up
so high i think
the big thing is teams are manufacturing
their own energy and there's less
pressure on some teams because usually
in their home court advantage like for
instance philadelphia before ben simmons
got injured every time he caught the
ball at home in philly everyone wanted
him to shoot threes
the crowd with gas there's pressure
playing in some
in certain environments and situations
in the bubble there's no fans there's no
degree of pressure
it's really who wants it more and i
think you're seeing
especially some of the elite guys like a
devin booker who's
it doesn't matter if he's playing in
front of 20 000 or two people
put on absolute shows tj warren
these guys have got a new lease on their
games because they're just going out and
playing and i think that's why scoring
and shooting is up
because more guys and teams are playing
more free and open
i don't know if you heard this it was
like a throwaway line from lebron
where he talked about something off the
court
but he said i don't want to get into
that now i think this might have been
after the game that
he had the quote i don't know what he's
alluding to here
but just the fact that you mentioned
that he mentions it
now that you know my curiosity has
peaked of wait what is bothering him
so much so that he would bring it up
during a press conference or kind of
bring it up there
i don't know if you heard that comment
from him i didn't hear but
let's remember now there there's so much
going on we're in the middle obviously
of a pandemic
these players still want to have their
voices heard
in terms of social justice so there's
there's still things surrounding and
affecting these guys while they're in in
the bubble so
i you know you don't know if he's
alluding to something off the court in
terms of
um his activism or if he's talking about
something internally that's going on
with the team
um you know it's hard to get a gauge on
on what's going on
with the lakers or lebron but yeah i
mean i'm sure that's a red flag comment
coming from lebron
who who sat out last night with a little
bit of a
growing issue if you had to bet a week's
pay
on the lakers or clippers right now
today i'm going with the clippers yeah i
just think
uh they're deep how they play the game
in terms of their length
um you know they got uh lou williams
back
i know beverly didn't play last night
but to me they're
they are the favorites to win the west
because of that depth
and they've got two guys and kwai
leonard and paul george
who can dictate the outcome of a game
at both ends of the floor and both are
young
both have experience in the playoffs
well coached by
doc rivers who's won a championship um
i personally would would lean towards
especially after
looking at the offense yeah uh you know
for the lakers
i'm leaning towards the clippers in this
type of environment
third best team in the west is who
i would probably go with
you know i want to put denver in there
but they've had so many injuries and
they don't have their starting lineup
though the way michael porter jr is
playing and they still have jokic
who looks great you know okc
people are not giving chris paul enough
credit
for you know everyone thought it was
going to be a pit stop for him this year
and he has oklahoma city playing at a
very high level
in terms of you know scary teams
i've got to put the houston rockets in
there in this unders
looking at them last night if they are
making shots look they're going to get
killed on the boards
we've seen that they're getting out
rebounded by 20 a game
but if they can turn you over which
we've seen and they can get out in
transition
and they've got two guys that flat out
put pressure on you
offensively on every possession in
hardin and westbrook
i would probably have to say the the
rockets are probably the most scary team
because of the unpredictability of what
they bring
with that six seven lineup and being
able to switch everything
and tj uh pj tucker defensively
what he did last night versus anthony
davis
was was phenomenal at the defensive end
reggie
called the heat and bucks last night
along with the lakers and rockets
tonight
it's celtics and raptors that's uh nine
eastern on tnt
here's the exact quote from lebron he
said
it's just some things that you can't
control that's here
that i really don't want to talk about
that's off the floor
so i don't know what he's alluding to
i'm assuming that has to do with
something internally
with his team maybe not in his personal
life
uh maybe he's sending a message to
somebody on his team i i don't know
kind of cryptic it is but it raises more
red flags because
when lebron speaks obviously everyone
listens
and that is that's a loaded you know
that's a loaded answer to a question
right there and you know more people are
going to probe
and try to find out what is going on
with the lakers especially
just by gauging the way they're playing
uh
the last couple days we've had some
people comparing a couple players to uh
larry bird greg popovich said uh jokic
reminds him of larry bird because he
does everything and then you've got
a few people comparing luca to larry
bird here
pretty high praise for these two players
of those two
who's more like larry bird in your
opinion
luca i love coach popovich
arguably one of my favorite coaches in
the league
both are talented in jokic and luca but
in terms of
larry bird larry bird was a straight
assassin score he would put 35 on here
and in a half
i don't think and he had that killer
instinct luca moore has that killer
instinct
offensively and can pass the basketball
he just doesn't have the size larry was
a true six
nine a big long six nine
seven foot is the joker and he doesn't
have that killer instinct
offensively he can score but he's not
trying to come in each and every night
and embarrass you
luca tries to embarrass you i think so
in terms of who's closer to larry bird
in my opinion
it would be luca doncic and watching the
game with the clippers
and the mavs and and while porzingis and
luca had good games there
there was something that was interesting
and that was kawhi
all of a sudden went into playoff kawhi
mode
and wow like that's it's it's tangible
you're watching it you go uh-oh
and then he said afterwards like he's
getting lost he's getting locked in
and you know he doesn't say much i don't
know much about him
but that was a look or there was a field
of the game and i know it's the mavs
but i saw something that is i rarely see
where you see somebody go i'm going to
flip a switch now i'm a different player
a different person
and and kawhi was like that last night
and to your point when you just asked me
lakers or clippers and then you tell me
about the quote from lebron
something's going on possibly internally
with my team
and on the flip side you hear the
clippers and kawhi is saying
i'm getting locked in right yeah so i
know
it's two different things and kawhi
when we talk about being able to affect
the game at both ends
look luca is a fantastic young player
but
kwai linda looks at that as a challenge
right
and they potentially could face in the
first round i believe dallas is
currently
in the seventh spot in the clippers in
the second spot so this is
a potential first round uh match up
and you've got kawhi and paul george
saying oh okay
we're gonna give you something to think
about in about 10 days when we see you
and i think they're trying to send a
message
yeah i'm trying to figure this out
though and it feels like the clippers
are just quiet they don't want to make
any headlines unless they go to a strip
club
they just want to go they're just
waiting where
you know everybody focuses on the lakers
either good or bad
they're the focus that now they're
shooting now they're offense now this is
a big deal as
you know we end up with the regular
season clippers are just
they're doing they're approaching it the
right way from the standpoint of not
saying anything they got a deep roster
there
got a great coach and you got one guy
who's done it before a couple of times
that
that value of having a player who's done
it and those other clippers
players are going he can do like i'm
waiting for paul george to be a big time
player
i'm waiting for that just like i am
anthony davis those are the two guys
that i want to see
so i think which which one of those two
steps up in a bigger way might decide
who wins between the lakers and the
clippers i think that much of anthony
davis
ability to be able to dominate what do
you think well theodore
look this is doc river slogan coming in
to the restart
win the wait and right now
and rightfully so the pressure should be
on the lakers
you you you know you go out and get
lebron james generational type player
you add anthony davis
they have the championship they have the
hall of famers they have all the banners
hanging in staples
for so many years the clippers have been
you know
the little brother so there's less
pressure on them
and i think they're approaching this the
right way that's why all the pre
the pressure is on anthony davis you
know
you've been first team all-nba you're in
line for defensive player of the year
this year
uh but you played in new orleans you
wanted out
you got out you came to the mega hot
los angeles lakers we mentioned all the
the hall of famers centers and power
forwards that are played in this
organization
so the lights are a little bit brighter
now it's time to shine you can't come
out and take what seven shots and have
you know nine points and then the next
game you come out and have 40
the consistency has to be there for a.d
and for the flip side for the for the
clippers remember
paul george was runner-up in vp last
year while his time in
in okc now he's had to take a back seat
coming to the clippers because you've
got a guy who's won
two finals mvp in kwai leonard but
i like the chances of the clippers
because of that length
and what they can do at the defensive
end um with all those perimeter players
theodore
every time i watch the pelicans i go
back to a comment you made
that it brandon ingram wasn't a big city
guy that he needed to get out of la
and that new orleans was perfect for him
lonzo ball had to get away from his dad
and the whole pressure there
and you know that it feels like he is
like these guys were able to exhale it
felt like they got there
but look at this lineup here and what
the pelicans have as they move forward
i i if you look at the nucleus would you
be confident that this is a perennial
playoff
team in what you have in new orleans and
if not
what do they have to have well is zion
going to be healthy
and play 32 to 36 minutes a game
do you think he can do that wrench
because
well he hasn't showed it right i don't
know if he's i think he's
you know great but i don't know if he's
there was an article yesterday a doctor
said uh he's in a race against his body
of you know as big as he is is he always
going to be this explosive
and then what do you rely on when you're
not that explosive and he's going to get
bigger
so i i don't know i hope he doesn't get
bigger
because look i love the strength and the
power that he plays with don't get me
wrong
but i personally believe he is too heavy
to be playing this and i think that's
why they have kid gloves on them right
now
i think they're managing his minutes
because they don't want a major injury
because i believe he is too heavy he
needs to shed
you know they kept saying you know
during the four and a half months he put
on
you know 10 pounds of muscle he doesn't
need
muscle he needs to be a little bit
leaner so
those joint the knees and the lower back
there's not so much pressure on there so
i hope
i hope going forward if they're going to
manage his his minutes
they need to manage his food intake
because he needs to take off
15 20 25 pounds
if he wants to play 32 to 36 minutes and
play
70 to 82 games next season
which they're hoping for the league is
hoping for
yeah um but he needs to
he needs to lose weight but do you
remember facing a young charles barkley
when he you know he was the mm-hmm i do
the
whatever the large round mountains of
rebound yeah
um but did you see how charles moved
when when his early days
in philadelphia uh it's a lot like uh a
zion
side i think zion was probably a little
bit more powerful especially
in his finishes and his dunks um but
charles never got hurt
charles never got hurt and he was able
to
even extend his career by losing weight
the older he got i just think zion
he looks a little heavy to me oh he is
heavy
and but but he's putting up like a point
per minute when he does play
so it's graham wailing
flame red's has got celtics raptors that
so you're doing that game tonight i'm
doing toronto boston okay
my raptors my raptors everyone keeps
talking about what did i say last week
when you asked me to no i know
i know and what have they done so far
they're undefeated
here in the bubble and they're taking
names
and no no a scary team yes they are
uh he's reggie miller he'll be on the
call tonight reg good to talk to you
have a great weekend
and uh we'll talk to you at some point
next week thank you theodore thank you
my dad nets